물가가 140, 150이면 만약에 간다면 코스피는 어떻게 보십니까?
그렇지
뭐 그쪽은 아니시지만
저는...
그쪽은 아니시...
나락으로 갈 수 있겠군요
나락당직
지켜드려요 지켜드려요
근데 그 말 속에 뼈가 있네요
아니요
나락으로 간다는 건 뭔가 안 좋은 얘기를...
자네 어디서 숏만...
잠깐 저쪽에서 숏 냄새 나서 못하겠어요
피디님 이걸 자꾸 숏...
그리고 저희 머니코믹스에 또 찾아주신 광고주님이 계시죠
바로 시킹알파
잠깐만요
제가 미국 주식 볼 때는 시킹알파 무조건 켜서 봐요
이거 뭐냐면 유명한 애널리스트들
우리가 사실 미국 애널리스트들의 의견을 어떻게 알겠어요
근데 그분들이 다이, 홀드, 셀
사실 셀 리포트는 저희 한국에서는 많이 못 보는데
미국 분들은 막 용감하게 쓰시더라고요
그래서 그런 것들을 저희가 볼 수가 있고요
여기 이제 알파픽스라고 해가지고
시킹알파에서 또
종목들을 좀 찍어주는 게 있습니다
그래서 평균 S&P500의 수익률보다
알파픽스의 수익률이 좀 월등히 좋은 부분이 있어요
그래서 여러분들이 알파픽스 종목만 좀 참고하셔도
아 요즘에 이런 주들이 주도주구나
이런 주들이 잘 갈 것 같구나라는 거를 대충 알 수가 있고요
이거는 이제 저희 애널리스트들이 쓰신 이런 리포트 같은 건데
구글 번역이 아니고
알파픽스에서 자체적으로 읽기 굉장히 편하게
한국말로 잘 요약이 되어 있습니다
구글은 다 매수라고 했는데
이 사람은 왜 매도라고 했지?
라는 그런 판단을 할 수 있는
어떤 근거들이 밑에 쫙 적혀 있으니까
여러분들이 이런 의견 참고해 주시면
그리고 한글로 딱 얼마나 보기 좋게요
요약이 되어 있어요
멤버십에 가입을 안 하면 일단 몇 개만 볼 수 있어요
그래서 여러분들이 판단해 보고
아 괜찮다 싶으면 가입을 하고
아 나 이거는 조금 그렇게까지 필요 없어라고 하면
가입을 안 하셔도 되지만 한번 들어가서 보셔라
미국 지식 리서치
맞습니다
가장 자료를 많이 모아놓은
시킹알파 사이트 이렇게 보면 되는 거죠
오 영리
전에 오늘
영리가 뭐야?
필 좀 제대로 받았구만
스마트한 청년 역시
시킹알파 광고는 여기까지 하도록 하겠습니다
여러분 이 더보기와 댓글창 참고해 주시면 감사하겠습니다
자 오늘은 진짜 제가 드디어 이분을 실물로
실물로 보니까 더 존잘이세요
아 씨
죄송합니다
죄송한데 무슨 뭐 베스트 애널분 모셔놓고 지금
본인의 사시머린 발언
석유화학 쪽에서는
이건 문제될 수 있어요
그냥 이분이 킹 2인자가 없어요 그죠?
윤재성 애널리스트는
너무 시선이 일로 가는 거 아닙니까?
자 알겠습니다
윤재성 애널리스트예요
어서 오십시오
네 반갑습니다
간단하게 자기소개 잠깐 부탁드리겠습니다
저 하나증권 리서치센터에서 에너지화학 쪽 담당하고 있는
윤재성이라고 합니다 반갑습니다
제가 또 SO1 주주로서
최근에 이 떨어지는 주식들 너무 마음이 아프고요
SK이노베이션도 갖고 있다가 손절했고
그래서 좀 마음이 많이 아픕니다
그래서 오늘 근데 사실 종목뿐만 아니고
이 석유화학 관련해가지고
이 산업에 대한 좀 기본부터 좀 알려주신다는
오늘 정말 어디 가서도 못 듣는 귀한 시간입니다 여러분
저는 최근에 유가 오르는데 왜 주가 빠지지?
얘기를 많이 들어서
맞습니다
그래서 그게 되게 헷갈리는 포인트들이 많아요
지금 현재 상황을 봤을 때
그래서 이론적인 부분들을 먼저 좀 말씀을 드리려고 하거든요
그걸 이해하고 우리가 얘기를 하기 시작하면
조금 더 판단하기 쉽지 않을까라고 생각을 해서
소재산업의 기본적인 특성에 대해서
먼저 이야기를 해보려고 하는데
소재산업은 결국 스프레드를 먹는 비즈니스죠
근데 우리 시청자분들이 스프레드가 뭐냐고
마진이죠 마진
마진
원재료와 제품 간의
죄송합니다
제가 대신 사과드리도록 하겠습니다
천천히
간격 간격
원재료와 제품과의 차이가 스프레드라고 보시면 될 것 같고요
알겠습니다
어떤 스프레드냐
그림에서 보시는 것처럼
제품과 원재료 간의 스프레드를 먹는 비즈니스입니다
그러면 제품 가격은 뭐에 의해서 결정이 될까라고 보면
수요와 공급에 따라서 결정이 되겠죠
원료 가격도 수요와 공급에 따라서 결정이 될 겁니다
그래서 결국은 우리가 해야 되는 거는
소재산업을 볼 때는
제품의 수요 공급 밸런스와
공급 밸런스를 이걸 따지는 거예요
그래서 이게 벌어질 것 같으면 주식을 사야 되는 거고
축소될 것 같으면 팔아야 되는 거죠
근데 항상 헷갈리는 게 뭐냐면
유가가 오르는 게 좋은 거야 아니면 내리는 게 좋은 거야
그리고 예를 들어서 배터리 같은 경우는
배터리 소재산업도 사실은 원재료가 메탈이잖아요
리튬이죠
리튬이 오르는 게 좋아 빠지는 게 좋아
이게 되게 헷갈리는 포인트거든요
그래서 이거를 그림으로 제가 보여드리려고 합니다
일단 왼쪽 그림을 먼저 보시면
원료 가격이 올라갈 때가 있겠죠
근데 원료 가격이 올라간다고 해서
마냥 좋은 건 아닙니다
1번처럼 가야지만 좋은 그림이 나올 수가 있거든요
제품 가격이 더 많이 올라간다는 거죠?
맞습니다
원재료보다 제품 가격이 더 많이 올라가니까
이 차익이 늘어나는 거죠
그래서 1번처럼 가야지만 우리가
긍정적이라고 볼 수가 있는 겁니다
회사의 이익이 늘어나는 거고요
반면에 2번 같은 경우는
원재료 가격은 올라가는데
제품 가격이 못 올라가요
그러면 차익이 줄어드니까
그러면 이익이 줄어드는 그림이 나오겠죠
그래서 우리가 원료 가격이 올라간다고 해서
마냥 좋은 게 아니라
1번과 같은 케이스는
케이스만 긍정적으로 볼 수 있다는 겁니다
제가 이때 궁금했던 게 사실
SOE를 가지고 있다 보니까
기름값이 엄청 오르고 있고
원유가 엄청 오르고 있다는데
그래서 SOE가 잘 될 줄 알았는데
또 그건 아니고
그래서 지금 이니님께서 주식을 샀던 거는
1번 그림일 거라고 기대하고 사신 거예요
원료 가격보다 제품 가격이 더 올라갈 거고
그러면서 마진이 벌어질 거라고 생각해서 샀던 건데
1번의 문제는 뭐냐면
너무 가격이 많이 올라가 버리면
수요가 위축되는 현상이 발생할 수 있어요
예를 들어서 항공유 가격이 지금 엄청나게 비싸졌거든요
그래서 항공기들이 지금 운항편을 취소하는 케이스들이 되게 됩니다
수요가 없어지는구나
너무 가격이 많이 올라가면
수요를 건드리는 상황이 발생하기 때문에
갑자기 수요가 죽어버리기 시작해요
그래서 우리가 판단을 할 때
마냥 제품 가격이 올라간다고 해서 좋은 건 아니다
수요를 건드리지 않는 레벨에서 올라가야지만
그게 우리가 꾸준하게 긍정적으로 볼 수 있는 상황이 펼쳐질 수 있다고 보시면 됩니다
네 네
원료 가격이 올라갈 때는 1, 2번 중에서 1번과 같은 케이스를 우리가 선택해야 되고요
원료 가격이 빠질 수도 있겠죠
그렇죠
오른쪽 그림입니다
3번과 4번처럼 제품 가격도 빠질 수가 있어요
근데 둘 중에서 4번은 어떤 케이스냐면
원료 가격이 빠지는데 제품 가격이 더 많이 빠지는 거죠
그럼 마진이 완전 위축이 돼 버리는 거잖아요
굉장히 불리한 상황이라고 보시면 됩니다
그나마 3번의 케이스는 원료 가격보다 제품 가격이 덜 빠지기 때문에
이 차익이 벌어지기 시작을 하죠
그래서 소재 산업은 이 네 가지 케이스 밖에 나올 수가 없어요
아
정답이 정해져 있네요
네 정답이 정해져 있어요
예를 들어서 유가가 올라가는데 휘발유 가격이 빠지는 건 이상한 그림이에요
그런 케이스가 나오기는 좀 힘듭니다
유가가 올라가면 휘발유 가격은 무조건 올라가거든요
한국 유가도 무조건 올라가죠
그래서 결국은 1, 2, 3, 4번 케이스밖에 나오질 않는데
근데 우리가 주가가 되는 케이스는 보통 어떤 케이스냐면
1번과 같은 케이스만 주가가 잘 됩니다
3번은 주가가 돈이 잘 안 됩니까?
원료 가격이 하락할 때 제품 가격이
제품 가격이 하락을 하니까 매출액이 줄어들잖아요
사람들이 그렇게 긍정적으로 보지 않는 겁니다
아
다 올라가야 돼 그냥 무조건
그럼 기본적으로 석화 소재 산업은 원료 가격이 올라가는 상황에서 기회를 찾아야 되네요
맞습니다 원료 가격이 올라가는데 제품 가격이 더 올라갈 때
그때만 기회가 분명히 있다
크롬 위원님 미리 당기는 질문인 것 같긴 한데
지금은 어떤 구매인가요?
지금이 1번으로 왔어요
오 좋아 좋아
1번으로 왔고요
1번으로 오면서 지금 1분기 정유 화학 업체들의 실적을 보면
전부 서파리가 났습니다
오 그래요?
1번으로 오면서 서파리가 났던 거예요
그건 아니던데
왜 그러냐 설명해 드릴게요
제발
자 1번과 같은 케이스는 어떤 상황이냐면
보시는 것처럼 원래 이 회사가 이만큼의 마진을 먹을 것 같잖아요
근데 이게 사실 말이 안 돼요
원재료를 지금 사가지고 지금 제품이 생산했다는 얘기니까
이게 실질적으로 말이 안 되죠
시차가 있다
원재료는 보통 한 달 전에 사놓거든요 한 달 반 전에
그러면 그림으로 표현하면 T-1 시점에 이때 원재료가 투입이 되는 겁니다
그럼 실질적으로 이 회사가 벌어들이는 돈은 이렇게 되는 거죠
더 커진다
더 커지는 거죠
근데 이게 우리가 계속 가격이 올라간다고 가정해 볼게요
우리는 매일매일 비싸게 팔아요
원재료는 한 달 전에 사놓으면 싼 게 들어가고
그러면 가면 갈수록 스프레드가 계속 벌어져서요
무한대로 발생할 수 있습니다
계속 올라간다고 하면
이게 결국은 시클리컬 비즈니스의 진폭을 결정한다고 보시면 될 것 같아요
그래서 지금 1분기에 실적이 좋은 건 1번과 같은 그림이 되면서 돈을 벌었다고 보시면 될 것 같고요
살게요
더 살게요
출발할게요
잠깐만요 아직 안 끝났어요
아직 안 끝났어요
근데 1번과 같은 그림으로 오는데 그러면서 이제 전반적으로 주가가 많이 올라갈 수 있는 상황이 되는데요
이 레깅 효과가 얼마나 무서운지 먼저 좀 설명을 드려볼게요
레깅 효과
지금 말씀드렸던 게 시차효과
시차효과
끌리는 효과
아 레깅
인터넷에 렉 걸렸어
아 렉 걸렸어
지금 엔터 쳤는데 렉 걸려서 2초 뒤에 나와
아 답답하지
지효? 바로요 바로요 바로요
이익이 더 벌어지는 그림이 나오는 거죠
레깅 효과 오케이
그래서 이 효과가 계속 가격이 올라간다고 하면 이 효과가 굉장히 커집니다
그래서 실질적으로 어떤 그림까지도 나올 수 있는 이런 케이스는 주가가 20배 30배씩 오르기도 해요
그게 2차전지 양극재 업체들 실제로 에코프로 BM이라던지 이런 업체들이 40배 50배씩 올랐잖아요
왜 올랐냐면 2021년부터인가요? 이툰 가격이 계속 올랐어요
양극재 평가가 계속 오르겠죠?
네
그럼 이 회사는 원재료를 싼 걸 투입을 하는데 제품 가격이 항상 올라가요
2년 내내 이어지면 언행이 너무너무 좋아지는 거예요
그거를 표로 표현을 해볼게요
예를 들어서 2025년도에 100억을 벌었어요
근데 이 레깅 효과가 갑자기 생기기 시작을 하면서 1분기 만에 100억을 버는 케이스가 생깁니다
근데 사람들은 어떻게 생각을 하냐면 어 이 회사 그러면 연간으로는 4를 곱해서 봐야겠네 라고 생각을 할 거고
그리고 왜 올라라고 했을 때 이게 전기차가 앞으로 100%씩 성장한대라고 하니까 여기에 대한 이 산업에 대한 밸류에이션을 주기 시작을 합니다
네
그래서 5배 밸류에이션을 줬는데 어 그럼 100%씩 매년 성장을 하면 여기에 대해서는 우리가 40배 50배씩 줄 수 있는 거 아니야 라고 밸류에이션까지도 올라가게 되는 거거든요
그러면 예를 들어서 제가 20배를 준다고 했는데 그럼 어닝이 4배 늘어나고 밸류에이션도 4배까지 줄 수 있으니까 곱하면 16배죠
와우 8,000억
텐백어가 나오는군요 텐백어
시총이 500억에서 8,000억까지 올라가는 케이스가 생기는 게 제품 가격이 계속 올라갈 때는 시차효과가 생기고 여기에 대한 밸류에이션까지도 주면서 이렇게 10배 이상의 주가가 생깁니다
아
근데 문제는
문제는
빠지기 시작하면
역효과가 나는 거죠
아
그래서 마이너스 90%까지도 빠집니다
2차전지처럼
네 그래서 가격이 빠질 때 절대 사면 안 되고요 가격이 올라갈 때만 사야 됩니다
아 그래요 근데 이거 이제 이해가 됐다 왜 그렇게 2차전지가 잘 갔고 정유주가 왜 이렇게 되는지
근데 문제는 지금 너무 유가가 빨리 올라서 천천히 올라야 돼요 이거는 천천히 오르면서 시차효과가 생겨야 되는데 너무 급하게 올라 버렸잖아요
네 네
그래서 더 이상 올라가면 수요를 건드리기 시작해요 그래서 제품 가격이 안 올라가는 거예요 보셨던 레깅 효과가 안 나옵니다
우와
그래서 지금 주가가 안 되는 거는 1번을 기대했다가 2번으로 가버리기 시작하니까 주가가 안 되는 거예요
음
그럼 지금은
지금은 유가가 더 올라가면 수요가 아마 망가질 겁니다
아 조금 위험하네 그러면
그리고 유가가 빠지면 아까 보셨던 것처럼 3번이나 4번으로 가기 때문에 사람들이 걱정을 많이 할 겁니다
좋은 게 없네요 그러면
좋은 게 아니야
좋은 게 없잖아요
지금은 사시면 안 된다고 말씀드리고 있습니다
아
근데 애널리스트님이 추천 종목 없음을 내셨잖아요 리포트를
아 네 네 저는 지금은 좀 기다리자
아 수준봐
라고 생각을 하고 있고요 그럼 언제 사야 되냐라고 하면 유가가 떨어졌을 때 떨어지고 나서 그 이후에 사야 된다라고 생각을 하는 거죠
왜냐면 유가가 떨어지는 과정에서 역마진이 나는 구간이 있을 수가 있으니까요 4번과 같은 그림이 나올 수가 있으니까
기다렸다가 유가가 안정이 된 다음에 천천히 올라가는 걸 확인하고 사야 된다라고 말씀을 드린 거죠
깔끔
지금 애널리스트 분 팬이 너무 많으셔가지고 위원님 팬이 많으셔서 막 슈퍼챗 막 3만원 5만원 쏟고 난리 났어요
감사합니다 여러분 슈퍼챗을 더 많이 사주시면
위원님에게 가는 거 없이
아니요 위원님께는 감사 인사를 드리고
계속해 주시죠
네 그래서 지금은 좀 조심해서 기다리자라고 말씀드리는 거고 유가가 좀 하락해주면 그때는 우리가 편안하게 살 수 있겠다라고 생각을 하고요
알겠습니다
근데 그 이후의 그림을 굉장히 좋게 보고 있습니다
그 이후에요
그 이후는 정말 굉장히 강하게 사야 된다라고 생각을 하고 있고요
그게 지금 돌아가는 판 자체가 우리 정유화학 업체들한테 엄청 유리한 판으로 흘러가고 있고
그게 말씀드렸던 게 중동이 힘이 약해지는 부분들이 우리에게 굉장히 긍정적입니다
그 얘기를 좀 본격적으로 좀 해보도록 할게요
재밌겠다
중동 호르무즈가 지금 막혀있는 상황이라서 지금 우리나라 정유업체들 같은 경우는 수입처를 다변화하기 시작을 했어요
원래 중동 기준이 70% 정도 되거든요
이번 4월달 기준으로 보니까 50%로 줄었습니다
대략 한 20% 정도 되거든요
20%포인트 정도가 줄어든 거죠
20%포인트가 줄었는데 어디에서 늘어났냐를 보면
미국이라든지 혹은 캐나다, 브라질 이런 지역으로부터 지금 원유 수입량이 늘어나기 시작을 했어요
그러니까 이게 우리나라 뿐만 아니라 아시아에 있는 모든 업체들이 다 이런 식으로 다변화를 하고 있는 상황입니다
일본도 중국도 다
대표적으로 태국에 있는 정유업체 하나 IR자료를 제가 보니까
중동산 비중이 90%였어요
근데 이번에 30%로 엄청나게 많이 줄었습니다
그래서 아시아에 있는 국가들은 모두 다 중동산 비중을 지금 다 줄여가고 있는 상황이라고 보시면 될 것 같고요
근데 늘어나는 지역이 어디냐라고 보면 미국, 브라질 이런 지역에서 지금 수입량이 늘어나고 있는 상황이거든요
그래서 이번 기회에 사실은 미국의 트럼프는 중동의 힘을 약화시키고 오히려 본인들의 힘을 강화시키는
미국만 노놨네 진짜
그런 그림이 됐고요
근데 미국의 원유가 경질 원유라고 합니다
그래서 이거를 우리나라 아시아 정유사들이 다 갖다 쓸 수는 없어요
뭔가 섞어서 써야 되거든요
섞어서 써야 되는 게 초중질 원유라고 해서 캐나다 원유라든지 베네수엘라산 원유 이런 것들이 굉장히 퀄리티가 떨어지는 기름이라서
미국산이랑 섞으면 중동 원유의 효과가 좀 납니다
효과가 나요?
1 더하기 마이너스 1 하니까 0 되는 그런 느낌이네요
중동 맛이 나는구나
비슷한 퀄리티가 됩니다
우리가 비빔밥의 인족이니까
블렌딩
블렌딩을 잘 하는 거죠
여기도 블렌딩이 필요한가?
오일 블렌딩
그래서 어젠가요?
그저께?
트럼프 대통령이 무슨 얘기를 했냐면
베네수엘라를 51번째 주로 편입하겠다는 얘기까지도 했어요
왜 이런 얘기를 할까라고 생각해보면
미국이 원유 수출을 막 늘리는데 이걸 아시아인들이 다 쓸 수가 없으니까
그러면 베네수엘라를 51번째 주로 편입을 해서
거기서 초중진류를 생산해서 아시아로 같이 수출하면 1 플러스 1으로 팔 수 있는 거죠
대박이다
그러면 중동 효과를 낼 수 있으니까 중동애들이 힘이 약해질 수 있는 상황이 볼 수가 있죠
그래서 UAE도 탈퇴를 했죠
그리고 이렇게 지금 베네수엘라 같은 지역들도 아마 저는 탈퇴할 가능성이 있다고 봅니다
베네수엘라가 OPEC 국가예요
근데 아마 미국이 이런 식으로 가면 베네수엘라도 탈퇴시킬 가능성이 있죠
그러면 중장기적으로 봤을 때 OPEC의 힘은 점점 약해지는 거고요
오히려 미국이라든지 다른 지역에서의 힘이 강해지면서
이제는 원유들이 남아 돌기 시작합니다
특히나 우리 아시아 애들이 받아쓰는 중진류들이 남아 돌기 시작할 거예요
그래서 이게 결국은 중동의 힘이 약해지는 것 자체가
아시아 정유사나 화학업체한테는 굉장히 유리해졌다라고 판단을 했습니다
그렇다고 생각을 하시면 될 것 같고요
그걸 그림으로 한번 보여드려 볼게요
이 왼쪽 그림을 보고 한번 얘기를 해 볼게요
원래 미국의 WTI는 좋은 기름이에요
그래서 비쌉니다
이게 두바이유랑 가격 차이를 그려놓은 건데
두바이유 대비해서 WTI는 원래는 비쌌습니다
2000년부터 2009년까지 원래 비쌌어요
근데 미국의 쉐일붐이 불기 시작했던 지난 15년 동안은
보시는 것처럼 WTI가 더 저렴해졌습니다
그러면 쉽게 얘기하면 미국은 원유를 싸게 조달을 해서
정제도 싸게 한 거고 화학 제품도 싸게 만들었던 거예요
엄청나게 유리한 상황이었던 거고요
아까 제가 1, 2, 3, 4번 얘기했었잖아요
3번의 그림으로 미국은 왔었다고 생각하시면 됩니다
그래서 이게 마진도 벌어지고 구조적인 리레이팅이 됐었던 케이스가
미국의 정유업체, 화학업체였다고 보시면 되고
특히나 미국의 정유업체는 지금 역사적 신고가가 나고 있어요
왜냐면 지금 보시는 것처럼 이렇게 싸게 원유를 가져와서 정제를 할 수 있는데
글로벌이 지금 정유 제품이 쇼티지가 나고 있으니까
마진이 어마어마하게 벌어지는 거죠
그런 상황이 지난 15년 동안 있었던 겁니다
근데 제가 말씀드렸던 게 이제는 아시아 정유사들이나 아시아 국가들이
중동의 힘이 약해지면서 중동 원유를 싸게 조달할 수 있는 상황이 될 거다
라고 말씀을 드리는 거고요
미국은 쉐일붐이 결정적인 유가가 싸지는 요인이었잖아요
쉐일이 이제는 끝났습니다
쉐일붐 끝났어요
경제성 있게 캐낼 수 있는 광고가 더 이상 없습니다
15년 동안 파냈으니까요
지금 과거에 뚫어놓은 유정들 같은 경우는 한 40불 정도가 BEP인데요
지금 신규로 개발하는 유정들 같은 경우는 BEP가 60불까지도 올라와 있는 상황입니다
이제는 파내려면 더 깊이 들어가야 되고 더 기술력이 올라가야 되는 상황이라고 보시면 될 거 같고요
그러니까 매장량이 없는 게 아니에요
매장량은 있는데 더 많은 돈이 들어가는 상황이 됐다 라고 생각하시면 될 거 같고요
그러다 보니까 미국은 이제 쉐일이 픽아웃하기 시작했다고 생각하시면 됩니다
이 그림을 보시면 되겠는데요
이게 미국의 2026년 이후에 원유 생산량 전망치인데
보시는 것처럼 생산량이 줄어들 걸로 예상을 하고 있죠
그러면 이제는 미국은 쉐일 붐이 끝났기 때문에
그동안 싸게 조달했던 원유 가격이 비싸지거나 그럴 수밖에 없겠죠
그럼 이제는 상대적인 경쟁력이 있어서 미국이 경쟁력이 떨어지는 거고요
아시아 정유사들은 경쟁력이 올라가는 상황이 된다고 보시면 됩니다
밸류에이션을 비교해보면 미국 정유사가 PBR로 2, 3배씩 받습니다
4배까지 받는 업체들이 있는데
아시아 정유사는 전부 1배씩 받습니다
혹은 그 언더거나
그 근본적인 원인은 원유 가격의 조달이 워낙 차이가 컸었다라는 점에 기인한다고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
그러면 저게 악재는 나의 호재다
그럴 가능성이 있죠
그런 면에서 우리나라가 장기적으로 좀 지금 좋게 보신다고 말씀하시는 거잖아요
맞습니다 원유를 싸게 조달할 수 있는 상황이 되니까 너무너무 유리한 상황이 되는 거죠
마진을 많이 남겨먹을 수 있는 거예요?
그렇죠 맞습니다
중동은 힘이 약해져서 원유 가격이 좀 내려갈 수 있고
그렇습니다 싸게 줄 수밖에 없고
미국은 나올 게 별로 없다 보니까 가격이 좀 줄어들고
원가 부담이 올라갈 수 있고
맞습니다
미국 업체들은 원가 부담이 올라가는데 우리나라 업체들은 원가 부담이 내려가면서
뭔가 글로벌 경쟁에서 우리가 샤바샤바 잘하면은 뭔가 될 거 같다
밸류이션이 올라갈 수 있다
올라갈 수 있다
이런 중장기적인 그림이 너무 좋다라고 말씀드리는 거예요
그래서 이번에 조금 쉬었다가 중장기 매우 좋은 그림이니까 이 그림을 보고 가자 라고 말씀드리는 겁니다
근데 그런 얘기도 있더라고요
최근에 호르무즈 해업에 막히면서 원유도 막 바다에 버리는 사람들도 있고
그 원유들이 아직까지 이 물가에 반영이 되지 않았다
그래서 물가도 비싸지고 전부 다 화학물질이다 보니까
이런 것들이 가격이 폭등하고 갑자기 대곰탕이 되고
그런 아포칼립스를 생각하시는 분들도 있어요
알상무한테 들었죠?
딱 내용이 알상문데
그럴 가능성이 없지 않다라고는 생각하고 있습니다
호르무즈가 개방이 빨리 안 된다고 하면
계속 장기적으로 이어지고
정말로 유가는 150% 이상도 갈 수 있다고 생각하고
시설들도 지금 다 폭발돼가지고 이거를 다시 재건을 하려면 시간이 몇 년씩 걸리는데
1년 이상씩 걸린다는 얘기도 있고요
사실 러우전쟁이랑 비교를 해볼 수 있을 것 같아요
러우전쟁 당시에 유가가 120불 갔었는데
러시아 원유가 안 나왔냐고 하면 다 나왔어요 몰래몰래 다 나왔거든요
인도도 가고 중국도 가고 하면서 다 나왔어요
근데 지금은 진짜로 원유가 못 나오고 있는 상황이잖아요
14%가 못 나오고 있는 상황이거든요
근데 유가는 100불밖에 안 합니다
뭔가 이상하죠
이상해요
이게 이상하다니까
그게 수요가 다 죽어서 그렇습니다
아
지금 유가가
러우전쟁 당시 120불까지 가지 않는 이유는
수요를 줄여놨고 거기다가 비축률을 많이 풀어놔서 그렇다라고 보시면 됩니다
근데 이게 시간이 지나면 지날수록 해결이 안 되면
정말로 러우전쟁 때 기록했던 120불 넘어가는 건 1도 아니죠
그러니까 이게 얼마까지 버티냐고
이게 지으려면 한참 걸리는데
내가 알상마고 어울리지 말랬죠
거의 없어 망한다 이제 이만하고 있어
그런 가능성이 있다는 거잖아요
그렇죠 이제 열리지 않고 6월, 7월까지 넘어가면 그럴 수가 있고요
지난주에 S&P 글로벌이라는 데서 6월 말에 호르몬즈가 오픈된다고 가정하고
유가 전망을 150불로 하더라고요
아 오픈된 거를 가정하고?
6월 말까지 오픈이 되면 140불, 150불 갈 수 있다고 전망을 하더라고요
비축률이 떨어진다고 이런 느낌으로 들어가는 겁니까?
그렇죠
그건 무섭지
정말로 비축률까지도 없어지는 상황이 6월 말, 7월 이렇게 되면 나올 수는 있죠
지금은 약간 불안불안한 상황이고요
이런 상황에서는 사실 이익의 가시성이 보이지 않기 때문에 주가가 되기가 되게 어렵습니다
아
그러면 140, 150불 만약에 간다면 코스피는 어떻게 보십니까?
그렇지
뭐 그쪽은 아니시지만
아니 저는
나락으로 갈 수 있기 때문에 나락 던지
지켜드려요 지켜드려요
그런데 그 말 속에 뼈가 있네요
아니요
나락으로 간다는 건 뭔가 안 좋은 얘기를 하죠
자네 어디서 숏, 숏만, 저기서 숏 냄새 나서 못하겠어요 PD님 왜 자꾸
아니 근데 최근에 제가 뉴스 보니까 일본 과자인가 거기에
이게 제품 가격이 비싸지니까 화학 이런 게 비싸져서 그 색깔을 안 내고 흑백 과자로
그래서 약간 그걸 줄인다고 비용을 그런 얘기도 있던데요
그게 결국은 수요가 파괴되는 현상인 거죠
그런 식으로 해서 계속 수요가 줄어들어 버리는 거니까 그게 이제 1A인 거고요
확산이 된다고 하면 어딘가에서 우리가 수요가 어떻게 줄어들지 알 수가 없습니다
그럼 그게 경기에 어떤 영향을 미칠지도 알 수 없는 거고요
우리도 뭐 과자 아이스크림 이거 비닐봉지 이런 거 다 떼고 흑백으로만 그냥 나갈 수도 있잖아
옛날에 동네 다니는 아이스깨끼 아저씨 있었어요 그 아저씨는 봉지 없었어
봉지 없어
그러니까 여기서 그냥 얼음을 이렇게 해서 하나씩 떼서 이렇게
요즘에 환경오염한다는데 그냥 다 옛날 거구나
ESG죠 그냥 봉지 빼고 이렇게 파는 거지 왔어요 하면서 이렇게 하시는데
혜자였는데 진짜로
맞아요
영혼 맞아요
그러면 제품의 수요와 공급이 굉장히 빠듯해서 마진이 벌어질지 안 벌어질지 모르겠는데
우리가 어떻게 할 거냐 그거에 대한 판단을 어떻게 할 거냐가 중요한 거잖아요
그래서 이제 그 얘기를 할 건데 왼쪽 그림을 한번 보시겠습니다
이게 정유설비의 글로벌 증설을 나타내는 차트예요
2022년, 23년도 이때는 증설이 좀 많았었죠
근데 이게 줄어들기 시작을 합니다
25년, 26년, 27년 이 까만 점을 보시면 돼요
까만 점이 순증설입니다
지어지는 게 있고 폐쇄되는 게 있기 때문에 까만 점이 거의 과거 대비해서는 굉장히 낮죠
그리고 28년, 29년도도 보시면 굉장히 낮은 수준입니다
이게 대략 한 50에서 60만 BTG 정도가 되는데
퍼센티지로 따지면 0.5%, 0.6% 정도밖에 안 돼요
근데 이것도 사실은 많다 그랬거든요
0.6%만 증산되도 많다 그러는데
이번에 전쟁이 나면서 피해를 받은 정제설비 규모가 일단은 글로벌에서 9% 정도가 됩니다
와 엄청 많네
근데 이 중에서는 원유를 못 받아서 가동이 떨어지는 애들이 있으니까 그게 아시아예요
아시아는 제거하고 봐야겠죠 원유를 소싱하면 가동률이 바로 올라가니까
실질적으로 정말 전쟁이 나서 피해를 본 설비들이 어디에 있냐라고 하면 중동이랑 러시아입니다
러시아 아직까지도 드론 공격 받고 있어요
그래서 이거를 합쳐보면 대략 한 500만 BTG 정도가 되는데
이거는 글로벌에서 5% 정도에 해당한다고 보시면 될 것 같아요
그럼 앞서서 제가 말씀드렸지만 한 해에 0.6%, 0.7%만 늘어도 증설 많아요라고 했는데
5% 정도가 지금 타격을 받은 상태고 이게 돌아가려면 1년 이상은 필요하다는 얘기도 있습니다
그러면 거의 6, 7년 치의 증설될 설비가 사라진 거죠 지금
어마어마하게 빠듯해졌다고 생각하시면 될 것 같고요
이렇게 빠듯해지면 유가가 올라가면 제품 가격이 더 많이 올라가요
그래서 정재마진을 보여드리면 이겁니다 왼쪽 차트입니다
정재마진이 원래 전쟁 전에 10불 정도 했었어요 보시는 것처럼
근데 90불까지 올라갔거든요 그럼 80불 정도 올라갔는데 이게 수치로는 어느 정도 되냐
이론적으로 말씀드릴게요 SOE 1불이 정재마진이 좋아지면 연간 영업이익이 3천억이 좋아집니다
1불에 3천억입니다
1불에 3천억이요?
잠깐만요 그럼 저기 90불이면 3천억 곱하기 80?
24조원
24조원? SOE 시가총액이 올라옵니까? 그러면 안 될 것 같은데
안 되죠 안 되죠 SOE의 올해 컨센서스가 1.5조원이었습니다
컨센서스가 1.5조원인데 저게 그대로 간다고 가정을 하면 말씀드린 대로
이론적으로는 24조원까지도 벌 수 있다고 생각하시면 됩니다
그래서 주가가 전쟁 나고 나서 그렇게 올랐던 거예요
주가가 지금 올랐을 때가 저 정재마진이 저렇게 폭발할 때 올랐거든요
이론적으로 계산해보면 어? 이거 연간으로 20조원은 넘게 벌겠는데?
그러니까 주가가 그때 상승했어요
아까 거의 가까이 2번 정도 갔었죠
근데 그게 말씀드린 것처럼 이어지기가 되게 어렵다
너무 비싸졌기 때문에 수요가 죽어버릴 수 있다
그래서 지금 정재마진이 빠지고 있죠
그래서 이 오버슈팅은 사실 이건 정말 오버슈팅이라고 보시면 될 것 같고요
그럼 정상화됐을 때를 가정을 하더라도 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
러시아나 중동의 정제설비가 오랫동안 못 돌아갈 가능성이 있고
실질적으로 설비가 없어지는 효과가 났기 때문에 전쟁 전보다는 좋을 거라고 보는 거죠
전쟁 직후보다는 당연히 나쁘겠죠
전쟁은 떨어지겠죠
근데 전쟁 직전보다는 지금 상황이 좋다는 거죠
정재마진도 좋을 거고 앞서 말씀드렸던 중동산 원유도 이제 다들 대체하려고 할 거니까
중동이 힘도 약해지고
원재료도 싸게 받을 수 있고 제품 가격도 강하게 유지가 될 수 있어서
전쟁 전보다 높은 이익을 오랫동안 철출할 수 있는 그런 가능성이 생겼다고 보는 겁니다
재료가는 떨어지는데 판매가는 덜 떨어지는
그렇죠 혹은 오를 수도 있는 거고요
근데 이거는 호르무즈 해협이 열린다는 전제로
맞습니다
열린다는 전제가 깔려있는 거죠
안 열리면 그냥 추천할 필요가 없습니다 사실
안 열리면 나락이야
안 열리면 그래요?
안 열리면 사실 진짜로 저희 섹터는 다 힘들어질 수밖에 없습니다
그냥 유가가 올라도 전가가 안 될 겁니다
1, 2번 그림 중에서 2번으로 갈 거예요 분명히
그래서 지금의 전제는 호르무즈가 열린다라는 가정을 갖고 말씀을 드리는 거다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요
그래서 정유 같은 경우를 아마 중장기적으로 돈을 많이 벌 수 있는 업체들이 될 수 있지 않을까라고 생각하고 있고
그래서 제가 지금 말씀드리는 거는
전쟁 전보다 주가가 더 빠지면 그럼 사야 된다
전쟁 전보다 상황이 좋아졌는데
그렇죠
이런저런 리스크나 시장 때문에 우리가 주가가 더 빠질 수 있잖아요
근데 전쟁 전보다 상황이 좋아졌으니까 밑에서는 계속 담자
그 이후에는 굉장히 많이 올라갈 수 있는 잠재력이 있다
그럼 우리가 화학 쪽에서 좋은 거를 찾아봐야 될 텐데
지금 보시면 이 엠비라텍스라는 게 장갑 만들 때 들어가는 원재료입니다
장갑이 그냥 장갑이 아니라 위생용 장갑 혹은 의료진들이 쓰는 이런 손에 쫙 달라붙는
수술용 장갑이라든지
라텍스 장갑이라고 하잖아요
이게 지금 장갑 재고가 없어서 난리가 났습니다
그래서 의료진들이 지금 부르는 게 값일 정도가 된 상황
의료진들이 안 쓸 수는 없잖아요
완전 필수제라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다
그래서 장갑이 지금 너무나 재고가 없는 상황이고
이 장갑이 재고가 없어진 이유는 뭐냐면
코로나 때 장갑이 엄청나게 많이 생산이 됐거든요
보통 장갑은 유통기한이 4년 정도밖에 안 됩니다
지금 코로나가 터진 지가 5년 정도 지났잖아요
그래서 다 유통기한이 지나서 폐기 처분이 되었습니다
장갑 재고가 지금 시중에 거의 없다라고 얘기가 나오고 있는 상황이고
그래서 이게 스팟 마진이에요
그러니까 지금 현재 원재료와 지금 현재 가격을 나타내는 차트인데
지금 많이 올랐죠
그리고 과거에 코로나 때가 보시는 것처럼
400불 했던 마진이 한 1600불까지 4배 정도가 올랐었죠
이런 그림들이 지금 그때만큼은 아니겠지만
혹여나 장갑을 만들기 위한 원재료를 확보하기 위한 움직임들이 나타나기 시작하면
이런 식으로 스프레드가 쭉 올라올 수 있겠다라고 생각을 하고 있습니다
이건 스프레드 마진이 느니까 금호석유화학이라든지
금호석유화학이 이 제품을 생산을 하고 글로벌 1등이고요
35% 정도의 비중을 차지합니다
그러니까 아마 이 마진이 좋아지기 시작하면
금호석유 같은 업체들도 꽤 많은 돈을 벌 수 있는 상황이 나올 수가 있겠죠
저희가 또 롯데케미칼이나 LG화학 이런 거 갖고 계시는 분들도 많거든요
근데 이게 화학이 다 좋은 게 아니고 또 종목이나 주요 사업에 따라 또 다른 거죠?
네 그래서 제가 선별적으로 지금
좀 봐야 된다라고 말씀을 드리는 거거든요
그러니까 모든 화학 제품들이 다 좋은 게 아니라
보시는 것처럼 이렇게 정말로 필수 재고
상황 자체가 이제는 재고가 없어져서 정말 비추를 해야 되는 이런 제품들
이런 제품들 위주로 저는 긍정적으로 말씀을 드린다 이렇게 보시면 될 것 같고요
그런 제품들이 또 하나가 더 있습니다
여기 왼쪽에 보시면 SBR이라는 건데
SBR 같은 경우도 타이어를 만들 때 들어가는 원재료거든요
근데 이게 지금 전쟁 전이랑 지금 현재의 마진을 비교해 보시면
전쟁 전보다 지금 더 상황이 좋아졌어요
그러니까 우리가 긍정적으로 볼 수 있는 그림이 되고요
그리고 재건수요랑도 관련이 있어요
만약에 종전이 되고 나서 재건수요가 발생을 하게 되면
트럭들이 많이 돌아다녀야 되잖아요
그럼 트럭들이 돌아다니면 이 타이어가 엄청 큰 타이어들이 필요합니다
그럼 그 타이어를 만드는데 이 SBR이라는 게 들어가거든요
재건 관련해서도 우리가 중장기적으로 긍정적으로 볼 수 있는 아이템이다라고 생각하시면 될 것 같고요
금호소규 같은 업체들도 긍정적으로 생각을 하고 있고
또 하나 그 오른쪽 그림 보시면 스판덱스입니다
스판덱스 뭐죠?
스판덱스가 뭐죠?
스판덱스가 레깅스나
잭시맥스
혼용률이 써있죠
보통 폴리에스터랑 같이 혼용해서 사용을 합니다
스판덱스만 다 쓰지는 않고요
스판덱스의 사용량 자체가 늘어나기 시작해요
실제로 양복 같은 경우도 스판덱스가 옛날에 안 들어가 있었거든요
요즘에는 되게 신축성이 좋습니다
스판이 들어가서 그렇습니다
필요합니다
혼용률 자체가 계속 늘어나고 있다고 생각하시면 될 것 같고요
그래서 혼용률이 올라가기 시작하니까 전반적으로 시장이 커졌던 건데
시장이 커지는 과정에서 너무 좋으니까
여기 보시면 2020년도에 진짜 너무 좋았어요
가격이 한 3배 가까이 올랐었죠
그래서 효성 TNC도 이때 주가가 좋았었는데
이게 너무 좋으니까 또 중국에서 증설을 또 어마어마하게 했습니다
그러면서 다운 사이클을 이렇게 겪었어요
근데 또 이렇게 증설을 많이 하니까 중국에서 업체들이 파산하기 시작합니다
그래서 실제로 중국에서 3위하는 업체가 최근에 파산을 했고요
그러면서 설비가 꽤 많이 줄었습니다
그러면서 지금 다시 고개를 이렇게 들이기 시작하는 거죠
근데 사실 이 석유화학 산업 하면 중국이 물량으로 밀어붙인다
그래서 한국이 좀 힘들다
그래서 산업 자체가 막 흔들리고 그런 뉴스를 많이 봤거든요
그런 거가 괜찮나요? 우리나라도?
중국과 비교했을 때 뭔가 경쟁이 될 만한 게 있나요?
그게 이제 지금 말씀드리는 이 제품들이 스페셜티 제품들이거든요
아 이 제품 말씀 주신 것들
그래서 중국이랑 경쟁했을 때 그래도 살아남을 수 있고
혹은 지금 잘하고 있는 이런 제품들 위주로만 지금 설명을 드리는 거죠
그럼 위원님
지금은 유가가 올라가면서 좋은 때는 아닌 것 같다
그리고 사이클이 올 것 같다 라고 말씀해 주셨는데
그러면은 뭐 나중에 좋은 사이클이 왔을 때 저희가 무엇을 보고 처음에 좀 알 수 있을까요?
가격이에요
어떤 가격이죠?
제품 가격입니다
제품 가격이 올라가기 시작하면 주가는 분명히 반응을 할 겁니다
그걸 저희가 어떻게 좀 알 수 있는 방법이 있나요?
그거는 진짜 그냥 트래킹을 계속 하실 수밖에 없고
하나증권...
윤재성 텔레그램을 구독하란 말이야
아 하나증권 윤재성 텔레그램이니까
거기 항상 업데이트를 해주세요
아 거기군요
그거를 사실 저도 몇 천만 원씩 회사돈을 들여서 이제 계속 트래킹을 하는 거니까
몇 천만 원짜리 정보가 들어있는
어디 날로 먹으려고
윤재성 우리 그쵸 텔레그램
자 위원님을 모시고 오늘 굉장히 수준 있는 얘기를 해봤는데
너무 재밌어
어렵기도 하면서
근데 분명히 뉴스와 업황은 좋은 것 같은데 주가가 안 가니까
이게 왜 안 가지 왜 안 가지
이 의문이 오늘 조금 풀렸습니다
알겠습니다
사람은 변하지 않는다는 거를 오늘 다시 한 번 알게 된 순간이었고요
자 의원
아니 위원님 저희
또 있어요?
저희가 사실 이 스프레드도조차 모르는 이 주린이들이 많은데
오늘 진짜 너무 쉽게 설명해 주셔가지고 너무 감사합니다
이런 주식 방송은 처음이시죠
죄송합니다
엔딩 면치려고
아니 말 좀 하자
아 해해해
야 야 빼라 빼 빼 빼
뭐가 궁금하십니까?
아니 제가 이거를 처음 방송에서 시도해 보는
시도해 보는 형식이에요
그림을 처음에 보여드린 이유가 이게 왜 안 되는지에 대한 이유를
그림을 통해서 기본적인 걸 먼저 말씀드리려고 했던 거예요
그래프가 1 2 3 4 있으니까 이야기가 쏙쏙쏙 되잖아
우리 다음에 또 한 번 어떻게 나와주시면 좋을 것 같은데
불러주시면 저는 감사합니다
자 엔딩 멘트 하세요
다 했어요?
다 했어요
다 했군요 예 알겠습니다
정말 이 석유화학을 보는 눈이 좀 띄어지는 그런 느낌?
저도 사실 몰랐거든요
유가가 오르면 산다 내리면 판다 이렇게만 접근을 했는데
뭐 확실히 사이클이 뭔지 우리가 뭐를 봐야 되는지 이제 아는 시간이 아니었는가 생각합니다
자 고프교출 빡주식은 지금 오늘은 여기까지 하겠습니다 여러분 감사합니다
안녕